تاسيس اينما تحدث عما يعرف بالتاريخيه تم
تحريف هذا المستوى عندما نتحدث الان
بمنتهى القبول وبلا اختلاف بين جميع
المسلمين على ان حتى يعطوا الجزيه على ان
هذا سياق تاريخ المنتج هل احد يقول اننا
نعطي الفيزياء الان او ان غير المسلم من
يعطي الجيزيه الجنيه يتحدث عن ان هذا سيق
تاريخي منتهي عندما نتحدث عن ايات الايمان
والعبيد داخل القران الكريم هل نحن نتحدث
عنها الان على انها سياق اجتماعي منتهي
اذا عدنا الى 200 سنه قبل ذلك لا يجرا احد
ان يقول هذا لان هذا القران ويقولون كيف
لا يقولون كيف لا يكون هناك ايمان وهذا
كان يحدث فعلا وكانوا صاربون بهذا بحق
شرعي الذي فعله نص انه كان سابق للزمالك
الازهر طرح مفهوما مشابها لما قدمه نصر في
ما يتعلق بالجزيه على سبيل المثال عندما
اعلن شيخ الازهر احمد الطيب ان مصطلحاته
اهل الذمه والجزيه هي مصطلحات كان لها
سياق تاريخي وانتهى
الذي حدث وتم التحريف للتحريض ضد مصر انه
قيل بان المصري يقول بان القران هو منتج
انتهت صلاحيته
مصر دائما كان يؤكد انا لاناقش ان القران
من عند الله او من غير عند الله انا اقول
القران من عند الله ولكن اتحدث فيه كان
رساله في بنيه لغويه في حاجه الى تحديد في
حاجه الى دراسه وفقا لطبيعتها كميه لغويه
حتى نستطيع ان نميز بداخلها ما بين
التاريخ ما بين الزمن المحدد وما بين
المعرفي الانساني الخالق ونحن حتى عندما
نقول في المعنى التاريخي حتى يكون هناك
تحرير في العباره نقول بان هناك حكم تعطل
حكم او خطاب انتهاء
قالوا انه انه هو بينكر
انه القران من عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
وانه بينكر
بيقول انه انه بشري
وبيقول انه منتج ثقافي وطبعا ده كله كان
عباره عن استهزاء يصل الى حد الجريمه
الكامله يعني لانه همم دكتور ناصر قال ايه
القران الهي المصدر
بشري اللغه والثقافه يعني الهي وينج من
عند ربنا
من عند ربنا لكن ربنا ينزله بلغه مين بلغه
البشر بلغه العرب باللغه العربيه